the Joe Rogan experience so you went to
Dubai to do a seminar he said all right
we'll stay here for a little bit yeah I
was doing divides very nice right yeah
but it's a bit like for me it's a bit
like fake like is everything is a
concrete jungle means the best way to
put it nothing grows there nothing not
even organic there you get the
raspberries and the the parish in a few
days like it so it's the desert really
yeah nothing grows yeah but it's cool if
you want to party like a waiter you just
go there any party and my just
mayweather party in Dubai everybody does
that rapper I've only been there once
Wayans yeah there was a fight there's a
fight in Abu Dhabi and we had the
weigh-ins in Dubai and we went there for
a day but I remember seeing no I didn't
go to that one this was several years
ago when Anderson Silva fought Demian
Maia okay and I remember thinking man
this [ __ ] for our ease everywhere and
Lamborghinis Rolls Royces a lot of money
yeah
Dubai has a lot of money you know that
this this crazy thing is that you get a
nice car like I get us I have a sponsor
I Drive a cool cars I'm not a drunk
McLaren you got a McLaren at me is my
yeah sponsor which one add the three
twenty-something yes I don't care I'm
not a materialist guy like what I found
my sandals on floor like I still round
them I don't I don't like I give all my
mommy somebody else's it was it was the
I had holes in it so I don't I think he
actually I really don't care about
including like this is a t-shirt from a
fan and yeah anyway I'm not a big big
material so you have a sponsor they gave
you a McLaren to drive yeah when I'm
there yeah so now we actually left there
and then we bye
yeah now we bought a place in we have a
house that we want to grow there in
Cyprus so now we live in Cyprus where
site is that's outside of France it's
Mediterranean so next to Jordan Egypt
Turkey it's like the most Eastern
country in Europe in you what brought
you there
you know what and it was I wasn't Dubai
when I went like I don't see we can have
kids here it's a bit like you know
everybody they're gonna grow with bad
values I really it's all about
materialistic about link you know
everything is about the money you want
to win a car you need to pay like to
have that one one one it's a million
dollars for that like it's all just bad
values I believe from oh you mean their
license plates
yes oh
one one license plate so it's not enough
to have a nice rule source you need to
have the one footer wrote so that's an
extra million that's hilarious they pay
a million bucks for the license plate
well had a bunch of dip shits that is
the dumbest [ __ ] thing who gives a
[ __ ] what your license plate says a
million dollars that's when you're just
running out of [ __ ] to buy and you start
you know like people buy exclusive
things there's only three of these
purses like well they should make more
it's so not important in our human life
like it's so not important this the
license plate thing is so weird you know
they have an issue with that in the
United States they have an issue with
people from other countries that bring
their cars over here okay like really
rich people from Saudi Arabia oh yeah
they call it Saudi Arabian summer
because in summer in Saudi Arabia it's
so [ __ ] hot that summer bro in
America seems like nothing so summer in
LA which gets to be 105 degrees they
[ __ ] spit on that they laugh at that
like that ain't [ __ ] yeah so they bring
these expensive cars like Lamborghinis
and Ferraris to shave them from the
summer and they bring them over here and
they bring them over here with Saudi
Arabian plates so they have like embassy
plates and they have like consulate
plates and you know it became an issue
in parts of Beverly Hills because like
they're not even registered and they're
they're not even registered after what I
don't know but they're driving these
things around like I was at a hotel in
Beverly Hills I went to a restaurant
there and there was a car that was
parked there like a Lamborghini that had
a like Saudi Arabian license plate I'm
like this is crazy
mm-hmm like how do you ever Saudi Arabia
plate in America how the [ __ ] the guy
was saying no it's like that the whole
thing about license plates it's like
it's like a sign of opulence then
they're able to ship their vehicle from
there not buy a car here and register it
here but ship or you drive their own car
here they bring it over here on a boat
oh my god yeah so they they put they
load their [ __ ] up on boats have it
brought up here they pick it up at the
document driving around with Saudi
Arabian plates like status I guess
there's when you deal with things like
oil money I think it gets to this level
that you and I will never understand no
level of money that just pour into it -
yeah
again I'm also a bit grateful because
now the highest suicide rate is in trust
fund babies people are born with too
much and they never worked for it
surrender unhappy so I think heart it's
okay to work for your goals you know you
feel more happy with it
[Applause]